Matt Babel Entertainment Tonight Canada
thank you oh look he was a Jew yeah can
I can't it up yeah like that I was like
I really can't about - I'm your father
nothing happening to me with his laser
eyes almost oh look a car rolling over
everything so it is anything I mean when
two men this handsome get together sure
you you had me at men
I mean is there initially a struggle for
dominance
oh is that establish dominance early
which is what I've learned so you know I
the first day I don't use my restroom
and my trailer it is just like a usually
like that place also known as my couch
yeah save ouch it's just carpeted since
through the walls is everything you know
you really want to get in there early
and make sure that you say they I love
that so behind here in my town now head
yeah all know known as London it's all
you get yes it's in the United Kingdom
Rebecca motley they've been great when
Rebecca was when we were wondering when
I just looked what's wrong with us yeah
when did this I wonder when did this
start
brew she said you guys have been
stealing the spotlight stealing sign of
the movie when the dispute look like
Bruin come to life right thank you for
saying romance for not bromance okay
did romance yes it Roman I think he said
romance overly okay women well I'm gonna
go with romantic he said right one of
the Romans start sillier it's in
dictionary by now right
romance well uh yeah what did it start I
mean honestly it's really started
honestly I mean when they take us out of
our cryogenic chambers you know like we
don't really get to do anything besides
to present ourselves in press junkets
and then do I don't really know him an
iceberg starts here right yeah but then
there's so much fun which is what we're
sort of learning about each other now
what was I mean how did it start
look in all honesty the first is and
laughing that was one of us like daily
this is like how it was it was like him
like everyone's it was like we're gonna
set it was non-stop this which is like
useless which you'll note from when
you're trying to pull footage from this
interview
and so you understand what daniel
espinosa had to go through and why he's
a genius
yeah because anyway look area it's no
champion and then this is sort of what
would with the big speed bump that was
in Daniels way every day was was I was
like that is the thing how does it lend
itself because in talking to everybody
it seems like there was great comradery
and light-hearted and such good times
how does that lend itself to this movie
that basically aren't in vanilla the
entire time I mean I think that's part
of it that's the wonder if Daniel Asano
the - yeah I go to keeping that tension
alive on screen but you know in between
tape it was mostly in between takes but
there were some of the bosses money that
we might have blown through heaven just
laughs but also that's also the dessert
a classic way generally like when you're
dealing with something pretty serious -
you know you can go to the other side of
it and then you just jump back and you
go hardcore to the scene and then you're
back out and you can joke you know there
was a lot of weird you know we were mad
using our imagination a lot of times a
picture this creature or so you know
each one of us had a different idea of
what was scary to us and we were
constantly facing it and the creature
then treated us differently based on how
we responded to it so Daniels is talking
to our ear all the time and telling us
so we would focus most of the time in
the take most of the time 40% is most I
mean if they like exactly over the line
of us but excited it's a failure under
manage an authority for this is
definitely failure yeah but yeah so I
mean I mean we are regardless of how we
behave now professionals so we got it
done but but it was great fun and then
the chart says zero G's the world we're
weightless throughout the entire stumble
on these wires which is exhausting and
tough so it's like it's easier to focus
when you're in pain so we had a lot of
that which is good I think we should
also see on on the screen but yeah in
between it was troubling give me a sum
from desperate intention well what is my
incredible which came on your head is
tiny uncomfortable drew but is that
there is online people are saying they
would love you to play cable and
Deadpool - oh that's sorry I apologize I
didn't know who I'm bad and is what's
called
yeah ice cream yeah I mean is it
possible can we make this happen well
for starters we either have to make his
body
pick a collar or his head six you said
bigger because better guys easily how
long this morning you're spent on this
he like woke up at seven and he was like
that picture so thank you much Wally
Lana Del Rey's head lipstick and
whatever happened it doesn't matter
we're never going to use that news
anyway because they won't make any sense
when they're talking although it's fine
no do you mind if I just throw mine in a
poke a hole to shoot the tongue thing
can i you mind if I just take that hold
it up with that in a minute here ah cool
yeah so I hope we answer that question